recently I made some simple changes to
my daily routine which allowed me to
double my productivity and I was able to
do this by implementing five simple
proven tricks for getting more done part
two remove distractions before they can
come up see the thing is even if you use
my advice and you go to a new location
there are still things that you might
bring with you that are associated with
past distractions let's move on to my
fourth trick which is to allow yourself
to win easily see oftentimes when we
tell ourselves that we need to get a lot
done we will set this bar way too high
so the thing you have to understand
about productivity is that it's mostly a
mental battle if you believe something
is too hard then you will naturally come
up with excuses to avoid even trying
which is why you got to allow yourself
to win easier lower your bar for Success
because then you can hit it more often
my final trick is to reward yourself if
you do not reward yourself your brain
will have no incentive to remember this
behavior and it will never become a
habit